- Пане Президенте, у Станиці Луганській сьогодні відбулося розведення сил.
- Не сьогодні, але воно вже відбулося, так.
- Який наступний крок до миру?
Наступний крок - у Мінську в форматі тристоронньої групи
будуть зустрічатися й говорити про те, щоб був
демонтаж бетонних споруд, які знаходяться
фактично з двох сторін. Після демонтажу, тобто
на останньому Мінську обговорювалося,
який потрібен для цього термін. Наша сторона
була готова за добу все зробити. Ми все для цього зробили.
А та сторона сказала, що їм треба від 8 до 10 днів.
Ми готові до того, щоб із їхнього боку був сигнал
і одночасно це сталося. Наступне питання
буде підніматися - принаймні я сподіваюся -
про обмін ув'язненими, військовополоненими.
- Як Ви збираєтеся налагодити спілкування
з українцями то той бік лінії розмежування?
- Потрібно весь час із ними говорити.
Ми постійно з ними говоримо. Ми туди посилаємо сигнали.
Ми говоримо про те, що ми всі українці, ми всі з ними однакові.
Ми готові робити те, що написано в Мінських угодах.
Ви знаєте прекрасно, що ні моя команда, ні я
не підписували цей Мінськ, але ми готові
йти по пунктах виконання всіх Мінських домовленостей для того, щоб нарешті у нас був мир.
- До них ще можна достукатися?
- Це комплексне, складне питання. Я думаю, що
багато нас чують. Я впевнений у цьому або,
скажімо так, хотів би в це дуже сильно вірити.
Ми будемо це робити наскільки зможемо довго, максимально.
- Після повернення Росії в ПАРЄ ви ще відчуваєте підтримку Європи?
- Я зустрічався і розмовляв із канцлеркою Німеччини пані Меркель,
із президентом Макроном і зараз із прем'єр-міністром Канади Джастіном Трюдо.
Усі говорять про те, що будуть нас максимально підтримувати.
Я дуже сподіваюся, що будуть якісь не просто слова,
тому що з ПАРЄ ми з вами бачили, що сталося:
це вже були не слова, а вже реальні якісь були вчинки.
Я дуже сподіваюся, що з їхнього боку будуть все-таки вчинки більш серйозні.
Не просто на словах підтримувати Україну, а будуть дійсно реальні дії.
Ну а що залишається?
Якщо ми хочемо закінчити цю війну,
а ми дуже хочемо дипломатичним шляхом,
то тоді інших шансів у нас немає. Те, про що ми
вже домовилися, - я сподіваюся, що це не зірве інша сторона.
Ми домовилися про те, що перша зустріч
після довгого мовчання буде в нормандському форматі 12 липня.
- Поки вони тримають своє слово?
- Ну, 12 липня… Подивимося…